hey folks
you caught me drinking is good to say
now with these earlier times we never
really have an excuse to be drinking for
the Q&A but today if it were just a
little bit later I'd be thinking about
it join you there those passionfruit
margaritas I made last night were pretty
good all right welcome back to the
thirty first Q&A livestream for the Dark
Horse podcast we are going to now match
our answers with your questions let's
see how we do all right so we're gonna
start with three that we didn't get to
from last time this one is in reference
to the black intellectual roundtable of
yesterday's chat it's curious that
religion was not mentioned which seems
like it could be a major contributing
factor no common moral framework or
commonality in which we mostly operate
under question mark each generation
seems less so and even anti religion so
it's kind of more of the comment than a
question but I thought it was worth
bringing up yep because it wasn't right
I mean no no one brought up religion I
know at least I know John Wood jr. to be
religious I don't I don't know all the
religious positions of everyone on that
panel but I know there's at least some
yeah yeah I would say this is a topic of
discussion in a lot of interesting
circles and I think we are going to have
to learn some sort of a new trick
there's what religion does traditionally
and there's what religion is and the
what religion is thing has become too
complex and what religion does has been
ignored because the is part has become
incoherent so my suggestion would be we
need to figure out how to address the
needs that religion is targeted at
evolutionarily in some new way because
this is not a moment you know starting a
religion doesn't make any sense taking
any of the various religions and trying
to get everybody on board that's not
going to make sense so in some we need
to have something that galvanizes
and causes us to have the expectation of
of adhering to something larger than
ourselves and I think there is something
to be said for the fact that we have
seen society become narcissistic and
solipsistic in the absence of a belief
structure that would tend to frustrate
those instincts indeed ok next question
when arguing what's behind black lives
matter I often run into what I call the
mr. burns syndrome where people say I
sound like there's an evil mastermind
behind it though there isn't it still
sounds conspiracy serious thoughts yeah
that's the problem is that you know it's
in part the big lie if you which is that
because all that out what that is well
the big lie involves that if you tell a
gigantic lie frequently and forcefully
that people sort of assume there must be
truth to it because it's hard to imagine
that you would be making up something so
transparently false and did this
originate with Hitler did he just sort
of publicize it and provide the world's
most egregious example yeah I'm hella
because I believe there's some ambiguity
about that but it's certainly the
context is Hitlerian so i think we are
all experiencing this which is as you
speak about what's taking place you know
there's some sort of a horizontal
revolution taking place in every
institution that does sound
conspiratorial and preposterous and
there's a temptation to imagine that
well normally that doesn't happen and so
whatever comes next will be you know it
will die down it will fizzle out it will
this will that when in fact some of us
are saying no it won't because the
amount of power that this thing has
discovered it has is immense and it is
not normal for something that has
discovered that it is powerful to just
abandon that power so you know it will
change but we're headed somewhere very
dangerous because of what we have
discovered the process looks like and as
you say that it does for somebody who's
not paying attention to the analytics it
does sound like you're being alarmist so
all I would say is alarmist is differ
from hypothesizing that there's a deep
dark force behind the thing that's
leading it right you know that that
could be one way to be alarmist but it's
not required by it and I think it's a
misunderstanding it's sort of a it's a
it's the comic book a vacation of our
understanding of what heroes and
villains look like that the idea that
you can't have bad things happen in the
world
absent a villain behind the scenes that
are rubbing his hands together and you
know making it all happen well you know
most most changes in history haven't
happened that way but those that have
certainly get a lot of play and they're
horrifying and in part it's easy to
track them because they appeal to our
also evolutionary desire for narrative
so when you have a human being who you
can blame and you can track what they
did and when they did it and what they
why they said they did it whether or not
you actually know why it's an easier
story to tell yeah that's true so there
is something about the complete absence
of leadership in this movement that
means at some level we are all reduced
to talking about a process yeah right
and talking about that process does you
know it's much harder to navigate rather
than being able to say well here's the
quote ya know and it's I mean it's part
of why it's been relatively easy for a
number of us now recently to say okay
white fragility is the book that's being
held up that that was written by a woman
and here's what's in the book and it's
nonsense and it's divisive and it's
dangerous but also you know the official
website of black lives matter is an
official website without anyone's name
on the masthead as far as I can tell but
it itself is changing right like so you
know a couple of episodes ago I went to
it and showed a number of the you know
the the the Pro trans before pro-women
sentiments and the anti-nuclear family
sentiments and that thing has now been
taken down yeah and before then before I
before we are doing these episodes there
was anti-israel sentiment which has long
since been taken down and so it's this
you know it's this moving target and
unless unless this is almost your
full-time job to sort of figure out what
it is they're promoting
make sure that you keep you know the
screen shot everything then there's
cover
they've got cover by not having clear
leaders because everyone is flawed every
individual human being on the planet who
has ever lived who ever will live is
flawed will have made errors at some
point and therefore if you're really
really really trying you can find
something with which to disagree this
protects against that yeah no it does
and it means that you you know how does
one read the elimination of the attack
on the concept of the nuclear family
being eliminated from the website did
they realize how insane that was or have
they just decided that that draws too
much fire and so they've disappeared it
and do they still believe it which I
certainly assume right then that's the
thing a leader you know you could you
could ask them Frank right what happened
to that thing but as it is even now if
you say to somebody look I support the
idea of black life black lives matter as
we've said many times black lives are
undervalued black lives matter is a
statement that outlines that that we
would support under normal circumstances
however we can't support the movement
because the movement is very closely
associated with this organization it
doesn't disavow the organization and so
the organization has a list of things on
its website you send somebody you say
look actually they're against the
nuclear family did you know that right
and somebody goes and looks now and it's
not there and it looks like you've
misunderstood right or you're you know
you're going on hearsay when in fact it
was right there well I mean we did show
that on screen and one of our episodes
I'm glad we did yeah
I'm glad we did it captures it so that
anybody who wonders whether or not some
of us are imagining things will know
that it was very definite or engaging in
hyperbole yep you know we can we can
then say you know when you ask
has it been taken down because they have
seen that that's not a tenable position
nor is it consistent with the stated
beliefs of the black lives matter
movement where do they take it down
because it makes it more difficult to
continue to get recruits who are
confused about what the organization
actually is I certainly suspect strongly
that it's a second
but that's that's he you know that's
just interpretation on our part whereas
is it up you know is there something on
the website or not you can point to it
and say yeah it's right there yeah yeah
okay final question from episode 30 that
we want to get back to you before
embarking on those from the last hour
I just watched Benjamin Boyce's full
documentary of the Evergreen incident
how did you survive there as long as you
did
you want to take it or shall I you can
start just I thought it warranted a
short response because we get me at this
a lot because the stuff I mean Benjamin
was there too and Benjamin graduated and
he learned a tremendous amount and he
also was subjected to some crazy stuff
inside his classrooms we didn't that
that we he was subjected to some crazy
stuff inside his classrooms some of
which we didn't actually have any idea
about until the end because obviously in
our classrooms we weren't subjecting
what that kind of right yet so we
weren't subjected to it but the key
thing to understand is how different the
experience of an evergreen professor can
be from a normal professor at some other
college when your students are taking
one class full-time and you're teaching
one class full-time you have this high
level of engagement that's involved in
the college that isn't connected to
what's going on in the wider College so
we had actually an extraordinarily
positive experience because by and large
we had excellent students our classes
overflowed with waiting lists so we we
had full rooms full of people who were
excited to have professors who invested
in them who cared about them
individually because that's the
experience they had in our classrooms
they tended to bounce between my
programs and your programs and sometimes
when we taught jointly we would have
even larger room full of these people
but basically the short answer is we had
a community of students that was
fantastic and so our experience day to
day was one that was invigorating and it
was just simply fun and rewarding to go
to work and interact and you know only
when stuff bubbled up you know in
faculty meetings or in other such
contexts did you get the sense that
something was very deeply wrong which
you know it was it was light until
Bridgers showed up right there were
little hints but by and large people
still talked about the fact that in
order to teach you had to make people
uncomfortable that uncomfortableness was
we're learning happened a core value of
the institution was teaching across
significant differences which meant that
you didn't have to look like the people
in the seats in order to convey things
to them and to learn from them you
didn't need to think like the
people in the seats in order to convey
things to them yeah look is easy and why
are we stuck here but more important is
think it's thinking basically all of the
elements of being human there was a
recognition that we were all going to be
different and that that didn't mean that
we couldn't have an educational
environment that functioned and then
those things in fact there was there was
not that much racial diversity at
Evergreen I mean like the entire Pacific
Northwest Expy was pretty white but
there was an incredible socio-economic
diversity and developmental history
diversity and you know the number of
students we had who were non-traditional
age was quite high in fact the average
age of students at Evergreen was 24 or
25 compared to 20 at most at most
schools number of students were paying
their own way who had no familial
support whatsoever was high people who
were veterans veterans you know who were
single mothers people who were coming
back to school after having raised their
own families people who've been home
school people have been on the skooled
there was a very there was a large
Indian population yeah the Native
Americans had in fact there were there
were a number of went like branch
campuses on reservations around the
state of Washington and we used to say
because neither of us thought that we
were going to become educators that
wasn't you know we were interested in
ideas and generating and spreading ideas
but the idea of doing it primarily to
and with undergraduates was never you
know the thing that we thought that we
were driven to do until we ended up at
Evergreen and found this model that
allowed so much in so much engagement
and really the back and forth and
playing with ideas and just you know
learning from one another that we
wouldn't have wanted to be anywhere else
it would be very very hard and limiting
and feel just impoverished to try to
teach and they standard you know 50
minutes a week three times a week kind
of situation again like that it just it
just would not yeah wouldn't it wouldn't
create learning community wouldn't be
satisfying job okay let us start with
questions from the last
do you think do you think it's possible
that the rise in perversion of
postmodern thought that is infecting our
major institutions and sense-making
apparatus is part of a calculated plan
by outside forces to destabilize the
u.s. from the inside out what it would
be easier for a foreign power to take
control in the midst of a civil war
yes it would yeah I would say a number
of things are true we've been watching
this school of thought gain power since
the 90s right and so it's very unlikely
that this was seeded by a foreign power
with intent that's it's too long a
period of time for it to have unfolded
however it doesn't mean especially in
our modern environment with algorithms
and the like it doesn't mean that
somebody is not taking opportunistic
advantage of our conflict over these
things and amplifying certain sentiments
because it is in their interest that we
be divided I mean the fact is divide and
conquer is well understood as a core
strategy for winning this is dividing us
very finely and in a way from which
there's no obvious recovery so it is
almost certain that our enemies will
have noticed that and that they will be
attempting to amplify it to what degree
that's what's going on I don't know but
I will say my discussion with the DHS
officer that we talked about in the
first hour one of the things he said
several different times was that he
believed we were being played that we
were being pushed towards racial
conflict and that that was not inherent
to who we were that it was somehow being
imposed I asked him who he thought was
doing it he wasn't sure but he had he
had the sense that that's what was going
on one hypothesis implicit in this
question might be that the effectively
postmodern takeover of the Academy in
the West and the u.s. in particular
could have been encouraged facilitated
with resources from
side and that's it that's a testable
hypothesis the idea that the rise of
these grievance Studies departments
Gender Studies and African American
Studies and Latin X studies and and all
of these things started I think it
started in the 90s but it really took
off sort of mid Otts
through through now and those
departments don't bring in any money and
in general what we've seen is a move
within universities a wave from you know
basically towards a business model in
which you are you are valued as faculty
and as a department on the basis of how
much external funds you bring in since a
large fraction of those funds then goes
to make the college run or the
university run so how were those
departments being paid for and I don't I
don't know the answer to that I don't
know how it was that so many such
departments got created once they were
there then you they were they had
effectively already gamed the system
because now when you count up
departments and say oh we're gonna have
a vote and see who wants to pass this
measure across the entire campus well
now we've got you know twelve
departments that are there [ __ ] but
they already exist so I want to I I
don't know the answer to the question
but I do wonder if there's just a
perverse incentive around creating those
departments mmm that basically I've been
that's sorry but I that's the high part
that's what we have been assuming right
that's and that's still what I think is
likely true but I actually it occurs to
me that I have no idea right the
committee funding might be coming like
where did the funding come from given
that those departments cannot pay for
themselves well I don't know that they
cannot pay for themselves in the sense
that students it doesn't take very much
if you have six departments that
basically are it's a pseudo replication
of the idea that all there is is power
and that looks that way from the point
of view of women that looks that way
from the point of view of this group
that group one after the other it's all
the same point right the I don't my
guess would be that the faculty in those
departments are not expensive the space
to teach is not X
offensive and that basically to the
extent that large numbers of students
think that they want to learn that what
they want to learn when they get to
college is about their own experience
you know close up with a microscope or
something like that that basically this
brings in tuition dollars gives people
something that it isn't hard for them to
get a degree in and so in a sense they
will make the trade
I could also I think I was disagreeing
with you up until that last point the
idea that these are effectively give me
degrees that if you if you get into some
school and then you decide I'm in a
major in one of those things I think
it's pretty hard to fill out yeah it's
rather sucks
you know without any rocks and actually
without each other either
neither rocks nor jocks but what you do
have are equally inexpensive to run by
your rubric departments things like
philosophy and literature that do
actually have standards at least they
used to and they still ought to because
we need the humanities those many
schools are are getting rid of those
departments they are slowly weaning you
know the the faculty way but the
difference is that it's harder and
harder to attract students to those
departments because it's just as hard to
make a living with a degree in
philosophy almost as it is to make a
degree with a living in Chicano Studies
but it's actually you're actually going
to have to do some work to get a degree
in philosophy and you know it shouldn't
be just as hard because philosophy is
real and you know we we we certainly we
know some remarkable philosophers who I
am quite sure when Christina Hoff
Sommers was on on a faculty somewhere
that she was actually educating people
and I believe that Peter Bogosian still
is when you know so long as he's allowed
to buy BSU as just two philosophers that
come to the top of my head whereas I
don't believe that students emerge with
much more than a sense of their
perennial victimhood
from the grievant Studies fields right
and so if you're talking about you know
fields that are inexpensive to run the
the grievance studies fields offer
people I mean basically by saying right
up front the
accounts is lived-experience you're
effectively declaring that there's
nothing to learn and therefore let's
hear what you faced yeah it's it's it's
a gimme for students and for faculty to
I mean this is this is about lazy
faculty do they create a situation which
they have to do nothing and demonstrate
that they know nothing which would be
hard because in many cases they do know
nothing and and and they're all you know
they get paid and the students get a
degree and it's a handshake in which
something of value in the market but if
no actual value in reality has been
exchanged yep next question I'm just
jumping all over the place
the pros suppressant Ovid saves the
lives of people who would have died had
they been infected before a treatment
became available when hospitals are not
at risk of being overwhelmed by what
mechanisms can suppressing the spread
save lives that's a curious question
yeah there's an a some there's an
assumption in here that I think isn't
right but I'm not quite sure what the
assumption is maybe the assumption is
that the only benefit the only way that
lives are saved by suppressing the
spread is because you don't end up in
hospitals which are overwhelmed and I I
think I think I get it if this is
something this goes back to the very
early discussions of flatten the curve
and herd immunity notice you haven't
heard much about herd immunity lately
because sophisticated people have
largely given up on the idea that this
is the solution yeah so well and and
much of the world is flattening or just
during the curve and we've decided to
try the second curve of even greater
magnitude right which ultimately I think
the question is predicated on the idea
that ultimately everybody gets it and if
the hospital isn't isn't overwhelmed
when you get there then when you get it
doesn't dictate whether or not you're
gonna survive and there's some truth in
that but what I would say is let's
imagine that a vaccine is possible we
don't know that it is not possible we
don't know that it is possible but it is
plausible that a vaccine can exist that
it will take time to get to one that
works
and from works we need to know that it
is safe enough to administer and so that
might be two three four years out how it
saves lives is what is the number of
people that we can prevent from getting
the disease through the date at which we
have some mechanism to prevent you from
ever getting the disease so that's one
thing and and we know that there is
there are morbidities that don't extend
all the way to death right that's that's
exactly where it's going is that the
other thing is that we are under
counting the massive harms that people
are experiencing even when they get it
and recover it's not everybody but it's
enough people and the harms are
substantial enough that we really need
to be thinking carefully about this and
then I would add one more thing to it
other countries have proven that they
have some different kind of wherewithal
in order to deal with this some of them
had easier puzzles to solve like New
Zealand but nonetheless they solved it
what are those countries gonna do if one
by one the countries of the world that
have the wherewithal managed to knock
this thing out do you think they're
gonna let us across the border right
we're gonna be able to travel we're not
we're not allowed across the border now
almost anywhere as I mentioned one or
two episodes ago and that's not gonna
change if we continue doing this but I
mean I'm talking permanently if we don't
beat this thing are we ever gonna be
allowed to travel to New Zealand again
probably not I mean would you if you
were New Zealand would you allow if
America had a problem continuing and
basically this thing settled into a
circulating cycle where it was
ever-present you wouldn't let this thing
back in no rational country would and so
this what does that mean with respect to
how the part of the world that screwed
this up is gonna be allowed to interact
with the part of the world that figured
out how to deal with it so at some level
let's rip the band-aid off let us
actually confront this the way it needs
to be confronted to stamp it out we do
not want to wait for a vaccine we want
to stamp it out and it can be done it's
harder now because having screwed that
process up once we have quarantine
fatigue or whatever you would call it
but nonetheless it's only going to get
harder and the costs to us are only
going to get great area if you know
if we are the holdout amongst the first
world that can't figure out how to stamp
this out next question refers to
something that has come up before and I
still don't know exactly what it is so
I'll read it maybe you know it print
what is your opinion on using a sort
ition to fill political positions
instead of our current method would you
like to see a successful unity 2020
start the conversation of moving towards
sortition thanks for taking the time to
do this show I don't know what sort
ition is I don't know what sort ition is
either let us say that sortition I'm
wondering if it has something perhaps to
do with rank-choice voting it's it that
that would be my guess I don't know so I
would say rank-choice voting is very
high on the list of topics discussed
inside the communities of people
interested in fixing the way our
political structure works so I don't
know about sortition have to look into
it but in terms of things that one can
do within the constitutional structure
we have there is a lot to be said for
for reorganizing how we count votes for
example in primaries etc so anyway look
for that you will hear more discussion
soon I see confusion online about unity
2020s goal of dealing with opportunity
hoarding and rent-seeking
as some view these as abstract
assertions can you provide specific
examples of these behaviors and practice
and how the current duopoly enables them
so let me before you answer that it's a
big question and we're not going to
spend you know that that could be a
whole hour but I also I don't know if it
was in the Q&A last time I also actually
stopped you at one point and said let's
just let's talk about rent-seeking is
because some number of people are going
to just think rent and think you know
cancel rent which is one of the you know
like abolish the believe defund the
police cancel rent so that we have
talked about that recently as well and
in an attempt to to deal with the
obvious problems of always speaking in
abstractions yep so let us talk a little
bit about rent seeking as it exists and
why unity 2020 which does not have a
platform nor does it
aim to have a platform would address it
we have many instances in which we have
a solvable problem that persistently
remains unsolved
so our incredibly cruddy way of paying
for and allocating the right to health
care is a primary example why can we not
figure out a system in which your health
conditions are dealt with as a matter of
distributing the hazard over a risk pool
it's not complex what the problem is
that is to be solved nor is it complex
what the solution is the problem is that
we have a an industry in charge of
something which markets cannot be
allowed to do because they will
inevitably do it poorly so if you are in
the insurance game and I don't mean if
you are providing insurance which could
be done well but if you are in the
insurance game in the sense that you are
an insurance company in competition with
other insurance companies you will
inevitably discover that the way to win
the insurance game is to insure the
people who are at least likely to need
insurance and dissin sure the people who
are most likely to need the insurance so
the job of insurance which is to
neutralize the risks that we face when
somebody has done nothing wrong and has
gotten a cancer we can distribute the
cost of paying for the treatment of that
cancer across the entire population
basically you don't know whether you're
gonna get one or you're not gonna get
one but we can all agree that I would
like it not to be ruinous if I get
cancer and so we can distribute the risk
across a large population but if my
insurance company is in the
profit-making business and it discovers
well actually we'd like to give the
insurance in case you get a cancer to
people who are least likely to get it
and we would like to dis insure the
people who are most likely to get it
because that's the way to enhance the
profits then what we end up doing is dis
insuring lots of people who are equally
deserving of being protected from this
hazard so in essence the solution
involves neutralizing the market forces
that surround insurance now who do you
think opposes that
people who are making a profit and
insurance why can't we solve that
problem why do they have a vote well
they have a vote because of the way that
things like lobbying influence policy so
persistently we are scratching our heads
and we have two parties that pretend
that there's some big disagreement on
how to make the system work right that's
gonna explain why they fail to solve a
decade after decade when in fact they
fail to solve a decade after decade
because they're both in the pockets of
these insurers whose racket involves
making money by preventing people from
having insurance who should have it
that's the racket right so that's
rent-seeking behavior the insurance
companies are providing some service
right but they are also getting a ton of
profit from something that is not only
not providing any useful service but it
is interrupting the service that they're
supposed to be providing so why would a
Unity 2020 ticket address that because
if you got Patriots in the White House
then what you would have are people who
had no incentive to keep the system
going and we're in a position to call it
out right there's an awful lot of power
in that it never happens the parties
arrange for that not to happen so that
we never solved the problem so that
their real constituents who include the
medical insurers never have to face the
terrible system that they've built so I
hope that explains it
next question what is the best method to
deliver funds to you where you retain
the maximum percentage this is about us
in particular you think probably PayPal
um probably pay pause that right mmm I
don't actually know what percentage
PayPal takes it depends patreon doesn't
take very much well PayPal doesn't
charge anything if the payment is goods
and is a friends-and-family rather than
goods and services and the only reason
that you want goods and services the
only advantage to you is that it's
insane some consumer protections if you
buy something on ebay from somebody
who's fraudulent you have some
protection that comes from the fact that
you paid them with that service for
which there's a fee but there's no fee
if you if you do it friends and family
so I
that's that's the answer beverage for
the fact that last I checked there's no
fee at all if you use that mechanism
patreon is better than YouTube YouTube
takes 30 35 and 40 percent which is
remarkable and it's been noted here
before and we are actually beginning to
think about working with some of the
wonderful people who have offered their
services to develop some kind of an
alternative to super chat so people can
ask questions and we can actually retain
a higher proportion of of what you guys
are generously donating to us yep I
would point out that YouTube is a
perfect example of this rent-seeking
issue and it you know it has the full
complexity because YouTube is clearly
providing a real service you know it's
massive server firms that make all of
this possible allow you to deliver
videos anywhere in the world at high
quality yada yada yada but the family
don't even have you know a price list
anywhere like no one actually knows
exactly on any given video or any
different question exactly what
percentage they're going to take is it's
pretty low it's it's all opaque and you
know to the extent that there's an
appeal it's like you click appeal and
it's either granted or it isn't by some
you know judge in the sky or whatever
but yeah
but the point is I think it's known some
fraction of what YouTube does is
providing a service and it takes a cut
and that's fair and then some fraction
of what it takes is pure rent-seeking
and you know I don't be interesting to
know what those two numbers what those
two percentages were but a rest could
have been done by the police and did not
require terror laws agents were marked
with police and DHS badges the cops used
unmarked the cops use unmarked cars the
tactic seems valid at the escalation I
understand the fear for abuse but do you
think it has actually happened so this
with regard to the discussion last hour
about NDAA yes
oh well NDAA but more specifically Trump
declaring a Tifa terrorist so I do
believe that there are abuses happening
clearly according to a standard
constitutional view because at the point
that the police take you off the street
they read you your rights then you were
under arrest at that
moment and taking you I can't say that
police do not take people into unmarked
cars I don't know enough about it but
for one thing there is going to
typically be a way to verify that a car
is a police vehicle if these are rented
vehicles right how do you know the
difference between somebody kidnapping
you like or the government kidnapping
you because they've got their fingers
crossed behind their backs to you know
obviate the utility of the Constitution
because oh yeah Barack Obama signed the
NDAA 2012 and you should read it really
carefully and consult the ACLU as to
what it means and you know yeah so
anyway yes I do think abuses are
happening again I would say I believe
the meaning of it is likely to be that
they are signaling you have triggered
that mechanism right so why would they
take people put them in the Federal
Building and then release them right
there's something yes they're engaged in
abuses but there is something symbolic
about the abuses they are engaged and
they are alerting people you triggered
those provisions therefore frankly
anything could happen to you and this is
again exactly why I didn't want
terrorism invoked in this context
because now we are in this murky gray
area that many of us have been trying to
call attention to for well since 2012 so
next question is similar the feds don't
appear to seek to shut down the Portland
riots if they did they could have
arrested and incarcerated without bail
10 per night 500 rioters would now be
off the battlefield your thoughts there
is no question that mayor wheeler is
hamstringing the Portland Police and
that he is doing so this is about the
feds in particular right it was the feds
don't appear to seek to shut down
portlets well okay so there's a question
about what the feds would be doing I'm
not sure that the feds is being used
specifically here because the feds the
reason that the feds are involved has to
do with these federal buildings which
are inherently protected by federal
officers now feds could be brought in
under other circumstances and then
there's a question about
protections in all but it would have to
be the Portland police or the State
Police who were doing the arresting and
there is resistance there is local
political resistance to doing any such
thing because Portland is so heavily
Democratic and there is a basically it's
virtually signaling by our our city and
state government and that is the reason
that the federal government is on the
front lines that was the dog
so anyway really the right thing to
happen is for the the city and state
agencies to do their job and to protect
Portland from what has become a nightly
violent riot but the political will to
do it isn't there which is I mean and
this is frankly this is a Miss read by
the politicians currently in power they
they think that they are dependent on
these Yahoo's for their reelection and I
mean they must else else the destruction
this is going to cost so much money and
time and an already economically
devastated City because every city is I
kind of like a devastated because of
Cove in nineteen and just just
anecdotally I will say that when I go
out and have to ship something the ups
or you know it if you PS or the post
office or just whenever I have an
interchange with someone that is brief
and no one's waiting behind me for the
interchange to end as quickly as
possible I am finding ways to ask how
are you doing what do you think what do
you think of what's going on and so far
to a person in which I am trying to not
betray anything about what I think
everyone whom I have spoken to across a
wide variety of demographics has said I
think there was reason to wish that our
policing was better and what has been
allowed to happen in the streets of
Portland is a travesty and it needs to
stop and I wonder where the leadership
is
I agree that that's where people would
likely be but the problem is the nature
of the movement is such that it puts
pressure on anybody who lets people vote
in private they do but so a I don't
think that this works like that where
people are going to say things publicly
and then privately feel very differently
and we that will be registered in the
vote because what's happening is people
are being placed in a position where
they have to agree to these these false
syllogisms and then having agreed to
them out of fear they then convince
themselves that that's what they believe
and so right or wrong mayor wheeler is
understanding the threat not to come
from the rioters but to come from the
people who with to signal that they also
believe that black lives matter which of
course is complex for all of the reasons
that we have said every time we've
discussed it right lots of people are
signaling that and you know it is
creating a power vacuum that the the
feds are now going to take advantage of
and you know basically we the citizens
of Portland have been left in a very
vulnerable position by that dynamic I
guess I'm just saying that I think
there's actually a tremendous number of
people who aren't who don't have their
feet being held to the fire by this by
the by the ideology inherent and what
the rioters are doing and and I think
frankly I think this is this is split
along pretty cleanly along class lines
and not at all perfectly but I think
most working-class people are watching
this saying what the actual hell like I
need to make a living I need I need to
have a job I need to have a downtown of
which I can I can walk and be and have
public transit that functions and this
is none of that and what is going on
with leadership and it's you know the
the look of these protests look it looks
just like it did on campuses its these
privileged kids who don't have meaning
in their lives and yes it doesn't look
like they're going to be able to make as
good a go of it as there
it's had and that is a tragedy and we
need to address that and that's what
occupy was about but this this isn't
mostly poor people or black people on
the streets protesting yeah on the other
hand you can see in the little episode
with with the majority report that you
know you and I have attempted to which
is which is a privileged white
organization I'm sure right this is like
an upper-middle class this is exactly
these people
well whatever it may be yeah you can see
that what we have tried to do is we have
tried to understand the complexity of
the situation and the complexity of the
situation because you do have violent
rioters in the streets nightly for some
50 nights in a row yeah there is a
reason that the protests are out there
it has to do with dysfunction in our
system that's real you have abuses by
federal powers you have a failure of
leadership at the local level so we have
not carved out a position on either side
what is now happening to us what we have
is a an Internet program that is now
painting a target on us that paints us
as part of the federal abuses right in a
case where we already have violence so
they are putting our family in actual
danger which means were we
timid we would avoid this topic so as
not to be in that danger right and
others will detect that they don't want
to take these positions because they
don't want to be in danger so the point
is the room to have any sort of nuanced
position here is being dried up by
threats that are being delivered in
public okay you know I agree with you
the sentiment would be there but I think
people are also detecting that there
will be nobody there to support them if
they attempt to take up a nuanced
position like yes I'm troubled by the
undervaluing of black lives but these
riots have to stop well I guess I mean
we need me to move on but I I guess I'm
saying no it does exist well I believe
that a lot of people do actually have
this position and they aren't people
doing this they aren't people with voice
there's no way to find them and
you happen to walk into a store where
they're working I mean he's these are
retail clerks I'm talking about really
and so that's a it's a weird totally
scattershot haphazard non you know non
survey survey but you know thinking of
this one woman in particular at a UPS
Store who no longer has her second job
at PSU where she was on the janitorial
staff she's a she's a Latina woman you
know probably in her 30s
I don't probably she has family I don't
know I didn't yeah I wasn't able to
explore that much with her but I didn't
even bring it up in her case she just
started I said oh it's quiet in here
today she said yep at least I have this
job at least I have this job I don't
have my other one I kept it through
covet and now because it was in the
heart of the riots it's gone because
they won't open it up because it's not
safe for us to be there and she was she
was eager to talk I was the only one in
the store and she was she she just went
off and I thought yeah I grateful for
the job that she has and cannot believe
and you know and she and she said she
said in this conversation look it's not
that I this Latino woman haven't
experienced abuses and racism of course
I course she has no right um but but not
this way yeah this is not how you do it
you know at all oh boy okay here we are
okay next three are actually a poem that
I'm going to try to read even though
they're all sort of stuck together and
then we'll do two more here and then
we'll move on to the next live stream
you ready 20 20 both both parties have
decided on a candidate that sucks if
only there was someone who could
out-compete these Schmucks I'd vote for
any Patriot with courage and a brain
corrupt septuagenarians logistically
insane what's that you say I have a
choice which stymies both their plans
and puts the Oval Office out of reach of
both their hands a ticket titled unity
on that my hat I'd hang I'd vote for
Yama Craven or perhaps McRaven yang the
old corrupt establishment will hate this
plan for sure and if we don't defeat
them their corruption will endure the
Articles of unity may be our best
out and choosing the best way is what
elections are about that from the
militant moderate hell yeah I love it
that's a beautiful that's a really good
poetry that's really good I'm glad I
didn't mess it up yeah it's good Huff to
write poetry that somebody can read on
first reading and get the cadences and
everything right that's no I did see it
during our break but but yeah it's it's
good good stuff thank you
well done all right two more questions
here and then we'll switch sorry to not
get to so many of the so many of the
twenty thirty dollar questions really
enjoyed the black intellectual
roundtable will there be more also I
didn't fully understand Brett's final
recommendation about what he thought
they should focus on was it corruption
okay first of all there will be more I'd
like to do another round table I'd
certainly do another round table with
the same folks but there are also other
folks who weren't in on that one who I
think would be great as well and you get
a very different perspective so anyway
that's potentially something that might
happen in the future there will
certainly be follow-up conversations
with individuals who were present in
that roundtable all right let me say
before you address this the second part
this question that you're gonna be :
Hughes is invited you on his podcast
you're gonna be doing that soon I think
yes I believe this week um I was gonna
stick with soon soon yes definitely soon
okay soon so anyway yes the
conversations are continuing and I look
forward to it I'm trying to remember how
the roundtable ended and what the
questioner is asking about but yes the
there wasn't enough room to explore
unity 2020 in that roundtable but the
basic point was we have a chronic
problem the chronic problem comes from
the corruption of our system which
prevents normal democratic mechanisms
from addressing it in the absence of
those mechanisms people are registering
that they are frozen out of well being
and they're reacting to it in a
predictable way and the solution to this
is to put them back in a position that
policy serves their interests and that
we can continue advancing the ball with
respect to making the country truly fair
and inclusive
so my argument would be that's the only
thing that makes sense voting for Biden
doesn't make sense because Biden is
going to end up amplifying he's going to
e and the DNC you're gonna cynically
partner with this movement which is
going to amplify racial tensions and it
is going to provide cover for the
rent-seeking
elites that have corrupted policy for so
long so I do think it's the right
solution because in effect the
conclusion in that roundtable and what
you've heard us say here is that we are
in effect in effect being divided which
is to someone else's benefit rather than
being United and galvanized for the
purpose of making America deliver on its
promise why don't we hear any talk about
getting the money out of politics we
used to we used to talk about that a lot
and and it has not been the main the
main thrust for the last few elections
since was it oh boy a mccain-feingold
is that the original it is but I also
think earlier in this process it might
have been as simple as getting the money
out of politics the mechanisms through
which corruption now functions are many
and varied so in essence you need an
anti-corruption set of policies that
deals with all of them because anytime
you leave a leak that leak is going to
be used to enlarge itself and ultimately
will be returned here so get the money
out of politics is I think a useful but
inadequate version of what we are now
talking about which is addressing all of
the mechanisms of corruption that
prevent governance from functioning okay
one more here it goes it's a it's a
timely comment I just found out that my
long term girlfriend is pregnant with
our first here's the Unity 2020 into the
conversations that will lead to a better
future for all congratulations and
here's to that indeed yep all right
skipping to the questions that have come
in this hour Zack have you drawn a line
I'm not seeing where
where we're supposed to be so while Zack
is drawing a line I'm gonna go up back
and pull in one more question from last
livestream which is this in your last
stream Brett said that there is a kernel
of truth within critical theory
what is this kernel and what reason do
we have for believing it the kernel of
truth is this everything that you know
that you believe that you think that you
conclude that you surmise all of it has
come through perception right whether
you were perceiving words on a page that
reported an experiment that you were in
present at or you were running the
experiment and you saw the results and
you took the data whatever you know had
to come through your perceptual
apparatus because it has no other
mechanism for having gotten into your
mind so that creates a hazard because
perceptual apparatus is not there to
literally report the world it's there to
efficiently report the world in a way
that is useful most of the time right
so that has biases built into it which
we call heuristics those heuristics can
cause prejudices however that's sort of
the end of the kernel of truth
right the kernel of truth is bias is a
problem right down to the level of what
your eyes tell you is in front of you
right sometimes it's so unambiguous that
there's no problem right the tables here
in front of me I can see it it looks it
looks like an actual object even though
the rendering of it is in my mind
however there are lots of things that
aren't like that so the remedy is the
scientific method the purpose of the
scientific method is to allow you to
detect what is true in spite of the fact
that your perceptual apparatus doesn't
register it correctly on first pass
that's what the method is for and so to
the extent that critical theory proceeds
from the observation that bias is
potentially and everything that you
perceive the right answer to it is yes
that's why we need more and better
science to detect the places where we
have misunderstood the world and we can
understand them and that has you know
that's true about everything including
racial bias so the kernel of truth is
perception is dangerous because it has
heuristics built into it but then
critical theory immediately goes off the
rails by then arguing against a
scientific approach rather than for next
question are the values of equal rights
and worth in liberal philosophy only
metaphorically true or are there
objective underpinnings to them
Jordan Peterson presents individualism
and religious that is metaphoric tones
yeah you know I've been thinking about
this and I think you can see what's
going on in the question about a
colorblind society so the idea of a
colorblind society has of late been
mocked because it appears so the way it
is marked is that it is as if people who
suggest that a colorblind society is
desirable have said that they don't see
race for example right which is
obviously an insane claim the point
though is colorblind it does not mean
you can't see race it means that at the
structural level it plays no role so
when you think colorblind think of blind
justice all right the statute with the
blindfold over her eyes and the and the
scales and the point is it's not like
the court can't know what your
background is but your background can
have no implication for whether or not
you know for how the law is applied
right something has to be criminal for
all of us or for nobody and you know
this fails we've seen for example during
the crack epidemic that crack and
cocaine were punished very differently
and there was a different racial makeup
of the people likely to get ensnared in
legal proceedings over using and
trafficking in these things so there are
biases in the law but the idea that the
law aspires to be colorblind is the
right objective it has to be the right
objective there's no other decent way
we're going to be able to run
civilization so what I would say is it
is not that the claim is that there are
no differences obviously there is a
difference between men and women that
difference is rooted in deepest biology
right some of it is superficial some of
it is very deep however you know the
crime
of murder if you kill somebody the law
has to treat you similarly if you're
male or female right it doesn't have an
implication about what you know whether
or not you're entitled to take another
life so I don't think it's a claim about
us all being alike it is a claim about
how the system has to view us when it is
rewarding and punishing us yeah
we've touched on this before it's a it's
a conflation of equal means the same as
yeah you know or means identical to yeah
our human sisters who share dad's rich
ex more related than brothers a second
question if we switched in embryos why
for another why would the baby have
almost the same genotype and phenotype
as a twin brother with regular dads why
so same question I don't quite get what
that first one our human sisters who
shared dad's rich ex more related than
brothers is is a fun one alright so the
idea is we've got 23 paired chromosomes
and at that 23rd position the X which
looks very much like all the other 22
pairs is a much bigger chromosome than
the Y bigger and has much more
information even right it's it's it's
bigger by mass molecular mass and it has
more coding genes on it and so that
means that actually females have larger
genotypes that and have large larger
genomes then then males and therefore
given that there's a larger genome to be
had with wow there's a larger sheet
entropy how it doesn't inherently make
you more related but it means that
there's because it depends on exactly
what no no I do I think the answer to
the question think the answer is yes but
I'm not actually I could just got stuck
in the in the nitty-gritty one matter I
think we can get there okay um tell me
if I'm wrong but me and you always do me
so if you are born if you're human or if
you are a eutherian mammals that thought
I'll cop to okay yes and you are you are
therefore born with
your father's un-- recombined
x-chromosome because he doesn't have a
second X chromosome with which wages can
the X recombine actually that's not
interesting itself I believe if you're
female and you have to exit if your male
can your X recombine don't think
something with which to recomm so if
you're a female you have an unrefined X
from your right there so you don't have
to say on Rican by that's all right I'm
just saying it so it's clear it's clear
with a logic comes from so the X is
going to be one of your X's will be
[Music]
unrecognizably then you have an
identical X which does drive up but the
Y is also one recombined so full
brothers also have identical was our two
sons have identical wise as well so nice
that's where I'm like trying to figure
out what the the larger genome but the X
that is a hundred percent inherited from
the dad for two full sisters as opposed
to a smaller genome but a Y which is a
smaller percentage of the genome that's
100% inherited from the father by to
four brothers which which one is more
fully related yep no I agree that's
that's a confound and so the problem
here is this depends depends on how you
do the calculation because the Y being
almost devoid of genetic content
intuitively seems like it contributes
less to the calculation right having an
identical Y that contains almost nothing
seems like it could contribute very
little that's a few important things in
motion
yeah right it's like the nuclear trigger
you know it yeah but anyway so I think
it's a different difficult question to
answer because you have to define your
terms and so how you calculate
relatedness you know as we've pointed
out in a prior live stream the fact that
you and a chimpanzee might be 98%
related but then let's say that you're
only 50% related to a full sibling
obviously suggests that those aren't the
same calculation so anyway it depends
define your terms and we can answer the
question although it would probably take
a little puzzling and a piece of paper
but yeah
the second question here I don't quite
if we switch if we switched in embryos
why for another why would the baby have
almost the same genotype and phenotype
as a twin brother with regular dads why
oh yeah so I don't I don't know what
regular dad's why I think I'm not sure
what regularly inherited I think is what
it means so the question is if you if
you could without disturbing the embryo
and that's a if but if you could pluck
out a Y and substitute a different human
Y it would have almost no implication
for the embryo and the developing
creature because and you know mind you
this is subject as far as we know as far
as we know but because their reason is
investigating series of events towards
masculinization but the way in which
that masculinization occurs doesn't seem
to be highly variable between y's right
it's basically a single signal that says
go down this pathway rather than that
pathway and probably it doesn't matter
which male you've got that signal from
the point is the content of what kind of
male you're gonna be is the result of
things on the autosomes that is to say
the non-sex chromosomes so yes i've my
prediction based on your question as
this echo would be almost died they
would be effectively identical twins
cool George Knapp was just on Jerry I
don't know who George Knapp is to you so
here's a fun one for you the question
continues do you believe that we have
been visited by aliens why are why not
no I don't believe we've been visited
bit by aliens because there's not
substantive
I will say you know I think you go down
this rabbit hole yeah and there's lots
of evidence of UFOs right lots of it
but UFO just means unidentified which
means you don't know whether it's your
own government playing game some other
government playing games
misunderstanding but well dude just
between you me and the small number of
people who may see this there is some
pretty interesting stuff that is now
being acknowledged about for example
military pilots who having
countered phenomena appears to defy a
natural explanation sure so what that's
do I think that's aliens having visited
the earth I do not I'm open to being
persuaded that it is no I mean I think
you know I I said no right away but we
got a question al while ago about I
think we got a question you know do you
think there's other intelligent life in
the universe
and my sense is it has to have evolved
whether or not it still exists now just
in terms of statistical likelihood and
the conditions necessary in all this for
consciousness I think it would be
stunningly unlikely for there not to be
some other form of intelligent life in
the universe I am more certain of that
conclusion than I am of the conclusion
that there have been no aliens visiting
earth I think it's really unlikely that
aliens have visited earth but there's a
whole lot that doesn't hinge on that
like you know we there's just a lot of
stuff that we can't know that we don't
know and I also have very little vested
in the answer so I mean I mean that
would be cool I think you know unless
they were here to kill us no it's uh
well two things one I don't know what
you mean other intelligent life is there
intelligent life in the universe I think
it's it's probable well our dogs in the
room but with respect to the UFO thing
yep if it was true I mean look if it is
true that aliens have visited the earth
then the evidence of that suggests that
they are actually actively visiting
right in other words these phenomena
that are difficult to explain through
normal mechanisms would suggest active
visitation if there was active is it a
ssin which I do not believe there is but
again that's waited that's a that's less
likely what that there is active ongoing
visitation well I mean you know it
depends what you mean you've got where
would they have come from right not the
solar system yeah elsewhere is right so
if they had arrived here from
we're over some very great distance and
we are seeing them in not only
historical times but you know with some
regularity we've see these phenomena
that are not explicable now again I
don't think that these are aliens from
elsewhere visiting the earth but if they
are I think the point is though that's
an ongoing something-or-other
so here's the question maybe if there's
an ongoing something or other okay
wouldn't it be worth our while to try to
reach them and get their help for
example for example were there aliens
who were interested in us for some
reason right Yeah right
you know a Starman waiting in the sky
he'd like to come and meet us but he
thinks he'd blow our mind
well maybe the point is well we're
willing to have our minds blown right
because maybe they have the secret to
fusion power do you realize how much
better the planet would get if we could
get fusion power and govern it properly
right we could solve we could not only
halt global climate change we could
reverse we could do all sorts if they're
here they probably do right well exactly
right we know it's possible so if
they're here right I'm not saying
they're here but I'm saying if we
thought they were here wouldn't the
thing to do be to try to talk them into
revealing themselves and helping us out
because we're in big trouble I'm not
kidding
it's a little bit like the right number
of lottery tickets to buy is one right
if you're wrong about the way the
universe works one lottery ticket allows
some force in the universe - yeah
solve your problems zero does not said
the guy who I think has never bought a
lottery ticket yeah right right yeah
nor has our dog nor by indeed okay loved
your interview with dr. mu and I'm
preparing for my eventual root
resorption since I had braces when I was
in my teens what are your thoughts on
evolutionary optometry oh so this is
like this is a question we sort of asked
on whenever we were first talking about
this and I don't I don't really know
who's doing this work although we've
seen a few we've received a few emails
suggesting there might be some good
people out there and we know we've
talked about this a bit yeah it's long
overdue I mean the fact is
you know ok there's there's words I mean
but the question presumes that it
already exists and we just don't we're
not in on the conversation yet I mean
we've talked about it but I am there is
some discussion of it whether there's
anybody actively working in
ophthalmology who has an evolutionary
bent that is you know above laughable I
don't know I have yet to encounter them
if they exist I would love to know what
what they're up to because I do think we
are screwing up our eyes badly that we
could be doing vastly better and that
you know this is just one more way in
which we squander human potential by
pretending that all sorts of
evolutionary things aren't evolutionary
so we welcome it if it's out there maybe
we'll hear about it yeah I don't know
what the next question means sjw equals
pora quarry Yakuza sure I'm butchering
that in Japanese which means PC mafia
seems like a more apt name what do you
think PC mafia I just I just can't say
anything about what the Japanese means
so yep know what the connotations are I
yeah I think you know we're gonna have
to politely sidestep that and say this
is its own phenomenon it's dangerous we
would welcome people within the
phenomenon waking up to the danger and
attempting to pursue actual justice in
some way that wasn't going to destroy
everything well both of you interview at
Richard Hart he's recently released a
product that is the dark horse of
cryptocurrency it's easy to use mmm
that's welding Zak you want to highlight
that uh the one I've got half assed
highlighted I did say when I was on
Peter McCormick's podcast his crypto
podcasts that I thought the key thing
was that crypto remains too hard to use
for it to catch on and the analogy I
used was the difference between PGP and
protonmail right protonmail works
because you don't have to exchange keys
and all it does it seamlessly and so I
was saying that crypto needs that layer
in order for it to actually achieve its
potential which I quite believe so
anyway maybe
maybe Richard Hertz got it yeah someone
has given a lot of money to ask to say
would love to talk find me on Facebook
landon doc hmm so uh I don't know if
Zach you want to highlight that to the
theoretical physicist dr. Sabet Sabine
Sabine Sabina so being Sabine Hassan
Felder would be a great interview guest
on the subject of philosophy of science
her recent book is titled lost in math
see also her blog and her YouTube
channel I know a little bit about her
for a long time yeah yeah quite quite
like her most of the time there's some
places where we differ but anyway yeah I
think she's a fascinating fascinating
person from my perspective many of these
postmodern movements at their core are
personal traumas being acted out
unconsciously on a mass scale how do you
combat something that at its root is
emotional and not logical facts don't
see him enough thoughts yeah I agree
with us and you know we're I think we're
often talking past one another when well
you know we are simultaneously saying
okay but you know this thing is you know
has its origins and post-modernism in
these traditions and then it was being
taught and indoctrinated at universities
well who are the people who were
particularly attracted to it some some
of them were actually interested in in
inquiry and an investigation of the
world and the role of bias in it I
presume but because as we already said
because the main the main product of
such investigations is your victim and
you always will be a victim and there's
no escaping that that will appeal to
those who are feeling themselves to be
victims and have not yet found any way
to escape from it it's a force
self-reproach waiting but it does it it
our explanation of it from the point of
you know grievance studies and the
scholars and the scholarship and quotes
behind it does miss the individual
psychological level and the fact that we
have so many people who are unregulated
dysregulated do not have any way to
confront their own psychologies and
emotions and
make real connection and meaning in the
world so I would just point out the
connection of this to the rent-seeking
thing because yeah what you have is a
bunch of people making a profit by not
only failing to serve the interests of
people but in many cases actually
maiming them psychologically and
otherwise you know yes so you know this
happens from orthodontia through a
pharmacological treatment of
psychological disorders you just have
all of these profit-making centers that
actually do a lot of harm to people and
have left them in many ways incapable of
doing what needs to be done
which then leaves them feeling betrayed
and they're not wrong that they've been
betrayed but they have misdiagnosed the
nature of the betrayal so yeah let's
deal with the rent-seeking okay let's do
who do three more
sure okay are there any schools left
that resemble what you loved about
evergreen for evergreen was actually was
unique there was there was no place else
that did that there are some schools
that did you know blog system you three
weeks at a time intensive with one group
of students and one faculty but being
able to be with the same group of people
full-time for a quarter or two quarters
an entire academic year and have that be
the extent of your academic work for the
year there's nothing else like that
actually and that there were a lot of
there are a lot of new pedagogical
structures that evergreen created when
it was formed in the late 60s early 70s
and some of them I think weren't as
important someone have been used
elsewhere but that thing right there
which was being dismantled in the last
year or two that we were there as well
was just it begun to be dismantled
really meant that there was no place
else
actually that was evergreen like in its
most unique and important feature yep
now if you were to try to set something
up that did that I would say we learned
a lot about what didn't work about
- and while our community was incredible
and that depended on the fact that
actually we were really interested in
figuring out what could be done with the
freedom that we had which was
essentially total um what I would
suggest is if you were gonna set up that
structure the key thing you have to do
is you've got to find the people who
actually are going to run with the
freedom and take it somewhere useful
from the point of view of students
evergreen brought in people who you know
it was very hard to figure out who was
gonna be good at the job of taking a
blank canvas and turning it into some
new educational environment so we got a
lot of cruddy teachers but we didn't
have a mechanism to get rid of them and
so they accumulated and what you want to
do I think and we tried to advocate for
this for some years before the end was
bring people in provisionally give them
three years to figure out whether or not
they can make the structure work and if
they can't it's not personal but they
don't they shouldn't be in those spots
and if you accumulated people who inside
of three years could figure out how to
make the most of that freedom you'd have
a great faculty and I mean that normally
existed but in fact once you've gotten
hired to a tenure-track position you
were almost guaranteed to get tenured
yep that's true yeah why is Unity 2020 a
better option than pressuring our reps
to pass anti-corruption legislation
because you won't be able to pressure
them because the people who have
successfully corrupted the system will
have vastly more resources with which to
exert pressure in the other direction so
the reason to go after the White House
is that it has the what's called the
bully pulpit and the bully pulpit is a
powerful position with which to to drive
the money changers out as it were okay I
said we'd do through her questions this
is to be the last room but I just found
one down below that's on a totally
different topic that we'll end with so
I'll get two more now argued with a
person who said all left-leaning people
are parasites on humanity similar to
Dawkins on religion how do we
distinguish between evolved parasitic
relationships for
evolved adaptations considering that
both last a long time okay this is tough
because the question is what level are
you doing the analysis in other words
parasites are adaptive if you analyze
them at the parasite level right at the
level of the host they are maladaptive
so in some sense you have adaptive
phenomena are those phenomena which are
coherent and advanced their own
interests now you can have mind virus
stuff on a short time scale circulate in
human culture and how are we to
determine that well those strategies
will be self-defeating over some period
of time so for example to the extent
that this ideology we are seeing in the
street is very powerful it is not stable
and so it's going to descend into a kind
of madness you will notice that it will
not produce the Utopia it's proposing it
will produce chaos right that tells us
that it is not an adaptive structure
short term it is gaining power but the
structure it creates with that power is
going to be authoritarian and it is
going to produce vastly more injustice
than the system it is replacing so you
can take that as a prediction okay last
question you said in Jamaica you studied
reptiles I have tons of animals thriving
in my garden any cool tips about these
dewlap flashing guys you could share
I've heard in the Caribbean there a case
study for convergent evolution so I
scrolled through and found the question
about lizards inside yes well I'll tell
you what I'll tell you a story so anyway
I was working with Bob in Jamaica rivers
Bob Traverse yeah the great evolutionary
biologist hi Bob if you're watching
anyway so we were capturing lizards and
we were counting things like scale
number to see how symmetrical they were
and we were measuring basically it was a
question of parasite load and
desirability to mates right some males
have this flag on their neck called a
dewlap that they
show and the they challenge each other
you know you'll have one channel and one
log and one animal and another log and
they'll start flashing their do laps at
each other and it's like game on and
they'll wrestle him do all these things
and so anyway we were also we were
taking the animals and we were measuring
things about their symmetry and all of
that so I was very much in the habit so
so sorry so you were you were engaged in
the test of the Hamiltons up hypothesis
which is a test that females are
choosing males based on their low
parasite load and their color in this
case their brightness will be an
indicator in inverse correlation with
parasite load the brighter the lizards
the lower the parasite load but you were
also testing questions to fluctuating
asymmetry what about females were
interested in particularly symmetrical
like bilaterally symmetrical males right
right thank you for the English English
translation it was vastly clearer than
what I was saying okay but anyway the
point was I was in the habit of grabbing
lizards and inspecting them and one day
I think Bob was getting ready to go out
for the evening or something and I came
into his room to talk to him and he
pointed me to the fact that there was an
animal on his dresser flashing its
dewlap to itself in the mirror and I
went to grab the anyone who's a at Dunn
do that because in some sense this
animal had come up against its ultimate
Mac I mean no matter how that guy is so
good he's so good all right and it was
just like no matter how many decimal
places you went they were dead even he
seems to predict by every moment yeah so
it's like that Marx Brothers routine
from duck soup oh yeah the mirror one
yeah
Beauty so anyway I did not collect the
lizard and we watched it for a good long
time angrily probably I did wonder
briefly if it was gonna catch fire but
anyway yeah so I don't know that there
any tips other than yeah watch them
they're fascinating creatures their
fights are interesting oh I know I did
one of the more interesting things I did
while I was in Jamaica was I decided I
was going to
one animal for 24 hours just to see what
life looked like in it was fascinating
so consistent I didn't know you did this
24 hours without you going to sleep well
the animal went to sleep sleep I went to
I went to bed took because it was clear
wasn't gonna move until sunrise so so
anyway you know this was a male it had
sex three times in 24 hours which I was
very surprised by it so these animals
have two penises one on each side and it
alternated sides that's not it that's
not done animal trait that's that's a
[ __ ] mate trip that's that's all snakes
and lizards have that yeah but anyway
the whole thing was pretty fascinating
yes okay so you pulled those sort of a
primatology move I think primatologists
work really really hard because they
basically have to put their monkeys if
they're watching monkeys to bed at night
and then get back before the monkeys get
up in the morning and start heading
across the forest in this case you the
the animal bedded down for the night and
like where do they sleep what are they
in a hole in a hole okay and so a I'd be
curious if they go back to the same hole
every night they're territorial mister
did but when you came back the next
morning presumably it was just was still
in the hole and then you waited until it
emerged and it did emerge and it was
clear you hadn't missed anything yep
unless something fancy was going on
inside the hole you never know you never
know can that could have been a portal
to another dimension oh yes all right I
think that's it all right well thanks
very much everybody
we'll be back on Tuesday a bit later
probably at the previous time like 3:30
or so Civic know on Tuesday all right in
the meantime check out Matt Taibbi the
black intellectual roundtable if you
haven't seen it Mike mu the most
fascinating orthodontist in the known
universe
and look out for more content because
there's more coming all right
be well everyone
[Music]
you
[Music]